so while i was away we had this uh i
mean it's i know people laugh at me when
i say it but it's the right word we had
this kafka-esque moment
where during another one of these
half-sold out public events with donald
trump and disgraced former fox news host
bill o'reilly donald trump said vaccines
are good and i got the booster and the
crowd started booing him and dr anthony
fauci was on cnn over the weekend and he
was asked what did you make of that and
basically dr fauci couldn't believe how
stupid trump supporters who booed are
now that's my characterization to be
clear dr fauci's words were were a
little softer he said he was dismayed
and he was stunned now at this point
being stunned by what trump supporters
do
were kind of long past being stunned uh
we're gonna look at that clip in a
moment but as a reminder here's the
moment from the trump bill o'reilly
event at which trump and o'reilly say
we've gotten the booster and the crowd
boos and trump tries to calm them down
but look we did something that was
historic
we saved tens of millions of lives
worldwide we together all of us not me
we
we got a vaccine done three vaccines
done and tremendous therapeutics like
regeneron and other things that have
saved a lot of lives
we got a vaccine done in less than nine
months that was supposed to take from
five to 12 years because of that vaccine
because of that vaccine
millions and millions of people i think
this would have been the spanish flu of
1917 where up to a hundred million
people died this was going to ravage the
country far beyond what it is right now
take credit for it take credit for it's
a great what we've done is historic
don't let them take away don't take it
away from ourselves you're playing that
you're playing right into their hands
when you sort of like oh the vaccine if
you don't want to take it you shouldn't
be forced to take it no mandates but
take credit because we saved
tens of millions of lives take credit
don't let them take that away from you
okay so the president made do you agree
with that
right
both the president and i are vacs and uh
did you get the booster
yes i got it too okay so uh don't don't
don't don't don't no none
that's a very tiny group of okay so
there it is trump vaxxed
trump boosted it's an accomplishment
it's great
and the crowd is booing fine
so fauci also in this clip that we're
going to look at was asked about the
candace owens trump interview which we
looked at earlier in the show in which
she does the anti-vaxx stuff
and trump goes no the vaccines are good
so i played that clip earlier but just
as a reminder so we have it all in this
clip here is that clip again which dr
fauci was asked about and will react to
we see the corruption right it doesn't
seem like anybody ever pays for the
corruption and right now we're seeing
corruption live even in terms of big
pharma which is a huge topic on the
minds of mothers especially you're
seeing what's happening at these school
board meetings where do you stand on
these vaccine mayonnaise and obviously i
know that you are you are pro-vaccine
obviously you did everything you could
to get this vaccine out i know it was
one of the greatest achievements we did
it in less than nine months to be able
to do that but where but now it's taking
a twist it's gotten now we went from
this is a good thing and people should
have this option to military men you're
going to have to resign because you're
not getting this vaccine where do you
stand on that well i stand on forget
about the mandates that people have to
have their freedom but at the same time
the vaccine is one of the greatest
achievements of mankind we would have
had a 1917
remember the spanish flu killed perhaps
100 million people actually it ended the
first world war because the soldiers
were so a lot of people don't know that
the soldiers got so sick it was a
terrible thing there was no vaccines
there would know anything i came up with
a vaccine with three vaccines all are
very very good
came up with three of them in less than
nine months it was supposed to take five
to twelve years
and yeah people have died under cobit
this year by the way under joe biden
then under you and more people took the
vaccine this year so people are
questioning how the vaccine worked but
some people aren't taking the ones the
ones that get very sick and go to the
hospital are the ones that don't take
their vaccine but it's still their
choice
and if you take the vaccine you're
protected look the results of the
vaccine are very good and if you do get
it it's a very minor form people aren't
dying when they take the vaccine about
the masking of children okay so those
are the that's the material those are
the two clips
that dr fauci is asked about
and he was asked about it yesterday on
abc so check out what dr fauci had to
say
you know it was interesting on this
question of vaccination i'm sure you saw
president trump former president trump
said came out and said that he
had received the booster shot he
actually got booed a little bit by the
crowd of support of his supporters as he
said that and now uh you know there's
another interview he just did uh with a
conservative outlet with candace owens
where he really pushed back on the idea
uh that the vaccine is not protecting
people he said that the people going to
hospitals
are
uh are the ones largely that haven't
been vaccinated you don't die if you get
the vaccine that those were those were
donald trump's words i mean it'll be
interesting to see if his supporters
listen to that
well i certainly hope so uh john we'll
take anything we can get about getting
people vaccinated i was a bit dismayed
when former president trump came out and
made that statement
and his followers boot him which i was
stunned by that i mean given the fact of
how popular he is with that group that
they would boo him which tells me how
recalcitrant they are
about being told what they should do and
i think that he's continuing to say that
people should get vaccinated and
articulating that to them
in my mind is a good thing i hope he
keeps it up yeah let's hope he says it
loudly now
yeah
trump telling people to get vaccinated
is basically a win-win unless you want
republicans to die and i know some of
you do but that's not my that's not my
thing okay so i'll explain
some of trump's followers are going to
hear trump say this stuff
and they will actually go and get
vaccinated and as a result fewer people
are going to die overall and that's good
and some of the trump supporters that go
and get vaccinated will also
prevent spread to some degree
and it's a good thing from a public
health standpoint so some people will be
convinced because trump said this and
that's fine
the ones who won't do it
and who get mad at trump for saying hey
the vaccine's good
they may become so furious and
disaffected
that they might abandon trump in 2024 if
trump runs and that's also a good thing
because it might weaken a possible trump
2024 run it might embolden a serious
viable primary challenger to trump in
2024 if trump does run and that can only
be good for the left if the left knows
how to take advantage of it now some of
you might say this is the third option
right
some of you might say david this is bad
we want republicans to die i don't want
anyone to die so i see this as a good
thing all around
and maybe it will keep us making
progress on the pandemic which by the
way with how contagious omicron is
uh it appears as though we are going to
make progress regardless of what anyone
wants to see and we're going to have an
update on that
either tomorrow or wednesday again once
we get the the latest data from the
holiday weekend now what trump could
have and should have done
would have been
to keep being pro vaccine on the way out
of office like all along he could have
said
hey i'll be gone but you got to get
those vaccines and of course he didn't
do that and it's too late to go back
but if trump had maintained this sort of
perspective or had this sort of
perspective as he was leaving office and
in every single interview that he did
just after leaving
it probably prevents a bunch of these
republicans from becoming so anti-vaxxed
in the first place but that's the ideal
we're not in the ideal scenario
obviously so this is another example
of when
the monster's creator
loses control of the monster that they
created and there's no way to undo it
there's no
sort of putting the genie back in the
bottle or whatever analogy you want to
use so very interesting and fouchy
visibly stunned by what we saw there
a few things i talk about frequently uh
government surveillance of private
citizens big tech corporations following
you around online
tracking done by isps of users
all of these parties can see things that
you're doing online if they can see your
ip address that's why you should hide
your ip address using atlas vpn
it's only a dollar 39 a month you
install it click one button it stays on
and you forget about it masking your ip
address like this also lets you watch
content on streaming platforms only
available in other countries it's really
easy it also helps keep you safe from
hackers and online identity theft you
can use atlas vpn's data breach monitor
to see if your personal info or
passwords have been exposed in online
leaks and don't forget you can also give
atlas vpn as a gift atlas vpn is having
a special holiday sale you get 86 off
comes out to a dollar 39 a month plus
you'll get three months free go to atlas
v dot p n slash pacman and use the promo
code pacman